welcome to this five minute game j-3
yeah this is some fifth no the sixth
game against him pretty even score
slight plus only okay oh this is the
line that is recommended by Boris a
Brook and his book the deform sidelines
book I keep forgetting the exact name of
this book between d4 sidelines or
something I don't know okay the capture
yeah I can go Quincy five Queen a 5c
five or six mmm yeah probably six try to
get this back quickly
no it tries to hold the pond okay yeah
there is as Bishop takes be items that
needs to be considered hmm but if I take
here first and then play b6 there
shouldn't be a big problem
I hope they are taking at the Czechia
[Music]
hmm
check yeah I was yeah yeah those checks
oh yeah it's got c6 and if I move away
c7 the rookie is very unfortunately
placed wow I think I confused something
here what is the big difference
hmm I think I need to play I need to
play knight c6 first right okay so what
what can I do here still I cannot move
something to this thing I really don't I
wait I have if I do 97 c6 I have Queen
f6 okay maybe c6 Queen f6 c6 Queen f6
takes on these seven Bishop d7 okay I'm
a one
so a bit of a disaster here c6 Queen f6
is really still playable I would be
quite quite amazing
it's got c7 a small my fruit be selling
them okay if it takes Bishop takes
Bishop b5 I can take this really I can
take you maybe this is still okay as
weird as it looks
c6 Queen f6 between a seven maybe Queen
a seven threatening to take here okay I
have no choice anyway if I gunite
somewhere less c7 c7 and I'm killed so
twin f6 and maybe he asked the Queen a7
could be a move you know intending to
take d7 interesting so I can actually
take now here
is there any intermediate move that
might make sense I didn't think so let's
let's be glad that I got something got
something here okay I still Queen eight
seven puzzle you know I cannot move the
bishop stole the c7 yeah and be five his
playing Queen a seven
this always c7 how can i play this keep
the age or something what do we had we
had position yeah I really think we need
7 is good but he's not playing it I mean
I don't see a response to that move but
ok this is this is of course also
dangerous
quite quite obviously so I cannot miss
the the piece still I can go here now c7
is good
[Music]
yeah this is probably also good right
still d7 hanging and I have no new this
this 95 coming check yeah I mean this is
really a totally terrible position
he missed several chances and it's still
totally lost 93 now is winning all the
time stop playing that but okay why does
as mentioned winning in multiple ways
there is no not just one way to win yeah
h5h for the only the only thing that
comes to mind here check
[Music]
yeah it's quite remarkable that the game
is still still on but it's lost yeah
still there was 96 threatened maybe I
should just no this is not I don't want
to exchange Queens this robs me of any
minimal hope and now he's got night
discoveries
[Music]
yeah 20-something seconds I can I can
resign of course but check yes hasn't
played so many winning moves that I will
continue for a moment check
[Music]
unfortunately it's it's so lost that but
he can play absolutely everything and
probably still a judge success certainly
winning somehow okay found it
okay black resigns yeah that was a total
opening disaster so okay this computer
gifts this is good for black amazingly
but do you know how do you actually play
that maybe yeah Bishop d6 is given by
the computer here I I didn't understand
many moves to be honest I mean this is
when Yaya out right he didn't play that
yeah I must play Queen e7 a king e7 year
the only move that not loses instantly
it was the first reading that he didn't
play ok and here there's this Queen f6
business should be six young I don't I
don't really know he should be six yeah
there was also Queen ace oops sorry here
that also was the screen a 7 move which
is quite strong but okay played this one
but also wins probably he has his seven
wins totally didn't play that okay
it's just a total disaster 93 was but
quicker and so on but it's it's just
like totally lost any any sort of tricks
that I can do not really yeah this was
just done just an opening a big opening
failure I probably have to play 96 yeah
I need to time this differently
taketake 96 hmm the immediate be six
there's still this kept showing be eight
so this is this is bad really
[Music]
interesting so maybe I need to take and
play this probably no not be five yeah
that's an entirely different position
yeah what I played is just losing be six
I mean I just confuse things he have
played this relatively quickly here but
I simply check I simply forgot about
those possibilities yeah it's a lost
it's a lost opening line so probably you
should improve somehow yeah you know I
remember I must I must start with this
move of course sorry yeah that's the
easiest way I only recently checked this
line and now I know I've no I'm
remembering this if I've threatened now
this is why white is probably obliged to
flip play this and now after six I'm
going to get it back easily
there is no before him before us it's
covered by the night so this prevents
this funny before business yeah this is
what I forgot and what made me totally
confused because I I just thought well
recently
there wasn't any before things happening
and Jeremy on
there aren't if you play it right okay
thanks for watching